[MUSIC]
We study consumers interactions when
sharing the pursuit of the same goal.
Customers initially joined these programs
to work on goals they value and
to seek companionship from others who are
pursuing the same goal.
As a result these consumers felt close and
shared helpful tips among the group.
However, we felt that this companionship
does not last forever.
Once people got near their goal and felt
more certain about their ability to pursue
this goal themselves, they stopped being
friends and stopped sharing information.
For example, we found that Weight
Watchers' members who were
successfully losing weight started sitting
at the back of the room.
Refuse to participate in discussions.
Stop sharing their experiences or dropped
out of the program altogether.
One solution for marketers in the
organizations is to emphasize to
consumers the uncertainty in how to
approach the goal.
To test this solution.
We designed a seven day walking program
and found that when participants felt
that they were pursuing the walking goal
for different reasons then their partner.
They felt less certain about how to
approach this goal.
And consequently stayed friendly, helpful,
and
shared tips until the end of the program.
Therefore, if we could make people feel
that they are still unsure about how
to lose weight.
The best way to quit smoking, or how to
earn more frequent flyer mileage,
we can foster companionship and facilitate
knowledge exchange among consumers.
This way knowledge, information, and
tools that can help consumers attend their
goals will be shared more widely.
After all, we're all in the same boat.